i was i was watching this video the
other day and it was like um it's not
blue's clue split it or not blues trust
me this is relate back to the top
okay okay okay so did you watch blue's
clues when you're growing up
of course what's blue's clues all right
so blues clues this tv show and
especially this guy
who was like talking to the camera kind
of like dora style this is where it
started this kind of style i maybe
didn't know but i'm definitely popular
where there would be like a task and
there was this you know a notebook and
they'd have to do x amount of tasks it
was a really good show actually
there was a dog called blue yeah okay
yeah and so that you the dog would help
uh steve steve yeah steve find all the
clues right
and um yeah so i always wondered i was
like why did he stop doing it because if
you if you watch the show
he basically swaps halfway through the
show with another actor
i thought oh that's where's weird why
did that happen so it turns out
that uh he was losing his hair and that
he didn't want to like go bald on like
tv right okay right right so
and then i was like [ __ ] that hit me i
was like oh my god
cause like i mean okay there's like tons
of comments about it and it's like it's
frustrating because like i don't really
give a [ __ ] anymore like
i've gotten over it but like
unfortunately my dad did not give me a
lucky dice roll with my genetics and i
am going bald
eventually it's gonna happen and
obviously it's been happening a little
bit
and it's so frustrating that people will
like go to other videos and be like
connor
yeah did you know you're balding and i'm
like pointing it out yeah it's like
and it's so frustrating because the
thing that bothers me is that like again
like i fully accepted that it's
happening i know people are going to be
like have you tried doing this have you
tried [ __ ]
doing voodoo and it's like yes
because people are always like hey just
just try pushing the ball because people
always like hey man just take these
drugs do these things like yeah okay
i've honestly like done all that tried
all that yeah unfortunately like
i can't do surgery either so whatever
and so i just kind of got to the point
where i was like alright i think i've
tried enough things or i'm like
this [ __ ] sucks yeah but it can't
really do much about it
right and so i kind of got over it but
it's really frustrating like i said when
people go to other videos and be like
bro you're balding it's like yeah like
like i'm i am aware
but it's frustrating that sometimes i
have to like edit videos differently
because it's like all right if i don't
edit this part out people are going to
comment about this instead of the
[ __ ] video and only comment about it
yeah
because it's like it's like i just want
to focus on the video and it's so
frustrating people feel they need to
point it out yeah
it's like why like yeah i mean i i know
exactly how you feel
because i too have not been luckiest
with
so like um so like pretty much everyone
on my dad's side who's a male
yeah same with the same yeah it's kind
of nice it's something that i knew was
always going to happen we don't think
it's gonna happen i mean yeah yeah like
as
as like when you're when you're a
teenager you're like i'm just like i'm
i'm i'm the exception
because your hair's like your hair's
like when you're like 18 your hair's
like warm it's lost yeah
[ __ ] man my hair's so sick as [ __ ] and
i'm just like you think i'm the
exceptional girl
and i remember um you know i've seen
like my entire family on my dad's side
everyone's
everyone's bold so i asked my dad i've
seen like pictures
of my dad when he was young and he had
hair down to here man he's bad yeah he
was or had dripped
um but yeah yeah he had a he had a
[ __ ] luscious
hair yeah and i saw what he looks like
now and i'm just like
so um dada when when did you start
losing your hair just just just
out of curiosity so just so i can take a
look and uh take a look at my own hair
and he goes
um i guess late 20 30 year old and i
asked this when i was 28 i was like
why did you not tell me earlier for
this is like i i can't i hadn't i had a
feeling like it's probably gonna happen
to me right but like i i didn't like
quite know but but then i realized okay
my older brother who's like 10 years
older than me was going bald and i was
like oh [ __ ] not a sweater all right
um yeah yeah and like i you know what i
totally get why kids think it's funny to
like mock
hairlines because you just think like
it's never gonna happen yeah yeah bro
i've got hair my hair is [ __ ]
luscious right now it's never gonna
happen
but it does oh yeah what is it like
[ __ ] two out of three
especially if you're white i think two
out of three men get like some signs of
hair loss or whatever all right
yeah but i remember like i thought okay
if it happens to me at 30 no biggie
you know it's by then i'll probably be
chilling out i'll be settling down
when i was like 21 or like 20 i started
to notice just a little bit it's getting
a little bit thin and i'm like
right what's going on up there huh
better put a timeout
so even when i was like 20 i started
like trying to do things to like help it
was you know doing those like you know
taking it all the [ __ ] fda approved
all that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
but unfortunately
for some people it is purely just
genetics yeah you just [ __ ] like some
people that helps and like
you know you do a lot of research you
look into it some guys
you might be in a place where maybe the
building you're living in has like
really bad case of like damp or
something that's [ __ ] with your like
your hair right
right so some people who you know their
living conditions are the reason why
they're losing their hair yeah
no unfortunately as i wish that i could
do something about it it was just kind
of like
whatever and it's it's yeah i guess the
the main
reason why i just thought [ __ ] it i'll
just talk about it because it's like
i've gotten to the point now right
people are pointing out anyway
it's it's like it's not going to stop
yeah yeah i feel like if we just say
something yeah facebook can at least be
uh
especially with a growing audience right
like new york is going to come into
being like oh this is the inside meme
okay
i'll add on to it for the millionth time
yeah because you know it's like
unfortunately it's just kind of a thing
of like
you know it's just something that i i
can't really do anything about and
unfortunately people are going to see it
you know because i'm not like i'm not
unfortunately
not going to you're not going to wear a
hat every day yeah my videos aren't just
me statically in front of the camera
never moving my head so it's like
you can't go anything further than like
a 90 degree angle otherwise
that's that's a red zone yeah yeah and
it was like so when i dyed my hair
blonde it wasn't that bad because my
scalp is like white
yeah yeah so it didn't look that bad but
it's when it starts to go brown and
certain lighting like especially studio
lighting [ __ ] reflect that [ __ ] yeah
yeah so where it doesn't look too bad if
you look at me like normally
in like video where the lighting is
washed out it looks [ __ ]
awful yeah right and it's like when i
see it on video i'm like [ __ ] it
that bad i check it i'm like oh it's not
too bad like that's what happened yeah
yeah yeah but
i'm i'm pretty much at peace with it and
i'll probably shave it at some point
because i kind of want to see how it
look
yeah i reckon you could uh you can
see like you have you have you lucked
out though in that regards because
the one thing no no like the one thing
is like you know like the fact that
you've already accepted that you're
probably going to go bowling like you're
probably going to get [ __ ] up
but at least the good thing is is that
you can grow a beard
yeah yeah there is nothing weirder than
a dude
who is bald
he's got the biggest dick in the
industry yeah sure and you know and
that's why he
like you know i can't say that in front
of johnny sims right because he probably
smacked
particularly across my face
but like you know at least like you know
a beard on a bald guy
usually nine times out of ten looks
[ __ ] great yeah yeah
you look you look hard as [ __ ] dude i
appreciate you trying to gasp me up here
jay
yeah yeah yeah no no but like that's
once but like it's weird because like
you know you you said like you know i'm
jealous of you joy but like i actually
had the opposite because like
i have too much hair i have too much
what a problem guys
because my because like your entire
dad's side right
dude they're like i think my dad was
born like [ __ ] 20. yeah
see my mom's side is exactly the same
because my granddad went bald at like
24.
yeah so for the longest time in my like
early 20s
my mom and my sister would just [ __ ]
egg me on being like when are you gonna
get that hair
you better enjoy that hair while you
still have it on your head boy and i'm
the head
oh that hairline's receding a bit yeah
and like i would like i remember when i
was like 18 i like asked my granddad
being like how old were you when you
like started to go to the ball and he
was like oh like
like 23 and i was like that's like five
years for me
[ __ ] but you know obviously i at that
point i was like
look if i go bald [ __ ] it i'll just
accept it you know like
i'd rather just like shave it all off
then like leave it half faster right so
i'm just like [ __ ] it
the more i thought about it and um the
more because i i can't actually get any
surgery even i wanted to because i have
my like a blood condition yeah
the more i thought about i was like do i
do i really want to just [ __ ]
desperately cling on to this
like at the end of the day i was like i
don't really think i give that much for
a [ __ ] where
i think i need my hair to function yeah
like i think i'll still be fine without
it like
that's the thing right like people like
i don't understand why people love
people
people make it seem like if you lose
your hair it's gone because it's like
a bald person right right i sleep
someone with full hair i sleep
balding free real estate for bullying
comb over comb over
is where it's at yeah i don't know
because people i feel like people just
want to have like at least some comments
out there i feel like they need to have
like a one up on you they don't feel
like they can mock you in some way but
like
but they but they keep mentioning it
like as if like oh if you lose your hair
you're not funny anymore like
was making fun of like something to do
with like genetics like a [ __ ]
slammed out to me i was like
it's like you you you you know you take
the piss out someone's look no no no too
far
boarding yeah it's like yeah oh free
real estate
it's not boring yeah like like it's the
same thing you're taking a piss out of
what someone was born with right like i
do notice like as you know as
someone who went through the phase of
you know like
just accepting that they were bolding
you know you do go through that
five stages there is like the first few
i think year or two when it's happening
you're like no i can i can reverse this
i can
i can reverse this five stages of
balding yeah i mean
i think you do right to any guys five
stages of acceptance
first is like you you what's the word
i'm looking for you uh
and i'm sure this conversation is quite
close to home to a lot of our viewers
because our audience is mainly dudes
yeah yeah if it is happening to you
don't give a [ __ ] man it's whatever just
whatever you're wrong i mean
you can do whatever you want it's not
like society [ __ ] rejects you yeah
because yeah
you know i feel like you know some
people are you know i i for one i have
been bored before
and i do i do
man yeah but i i do like my hair and you
know i am putting in steps to
you know i i don't expect to keep this
forever but i would like to
elongate it for as long as i can you
know i'm like me too
i'm self-aware enough to know that you
know once it's past the point
all right yeah i got it too far it's
gone but at least at least right now
when i still have this hair i'm gonna be
like okay you know i'm gonna lose this
eventually yeah
but i am going to try and do my best at
this point to just keep it and i don't
think
there's anything particularly wrong
about it there's no there's nothing
particularly wrong
with either direction that you go to all
right i think it's more just
you know i some some people i you know i
like the feeling of having hair i like
the feeling
i like the feeling of you know washing
your hair and
my god especially [ __ ] one thing that
nobody tells you about being bold
right it's cold right it's [ __ ] cold
okay
you're either cold or if you're in a hot
humid country like
thailand [ __ ] mosquitoes it's free
real estate
there's an extra surface area for the
mosquitoes just go [ __ ] mental
i i do it it's like a park that just
open right
i won't lie i do like the idea of being
able to optimize my bathing experience
which is like
your bathing type is like cut by half
and like when you get out
bro you're immediately dropped that
sounds amazing you know how like you
know
hurry i am a single wife and also like
do you use i mean shampoo is irrelevant
right yeah yeah yeah
you save so much money dude what the
[ __ ] i hate having to find like organic
[ __ ] shampoo that isn't like full of
like sulfates or something yeah yeah